[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima
after weeks of scandal speculation and
punchy promos the whole cast was just
shocked and confused
the bachelor in paradise season premiere
was finally upon us again we got not a
lot but what we wanted to see was more
footage concerning the Corrine elympios
Demario Jackson fall out but Monday
night's premiere pretty much only showed
what we had already seen in promos added
on were some scenes with Chris Harrison
him sitting on an empty paradise set I'm
still here alone on the set of Bachelor
paradise and at the end of Monday night
fans were teased again promised this on
Tuesday night's episode the bachelors
and bachelorettes return to Mexico
restarting this whole thing raised a lot
of questions for all of us yes there's a
part two of the premiere airing on
Tuesday night and yes we will watch to
find out what happens but were you
disappointed did you want more answers
on what happened with Corinne and Mario
let me know over on Twitter
you